another big development today president
biden is expected to announce a new
federal strategy to fight the pandemic
nancy cordes is at the white house for
us once again with more on what to
expect nancy good morning
good morning tony the white house is
calling this a robust plan to combat
rising covid cases but we'll have to
wait until later today to see whether it
includes any major new policies like the
one under consideration in los angeles
here are the broad goals behind the
white house plan six focus areas
including increasing testing requiring
masks keeping schools safely open
protecting the fragile economic recovery
improving care and getting shots in the
arms of the unvaccinated now this recent
surge of cases the white house concedes
could endanger the economic recovery
especially now that some of the
protections the president supported have
expired like increased unemployment
benefits and that eviction moratorium a
source familiar with the strategy tells
cbs news that the president will provide
an update on booster shots today we'll
also hear from him on vaccine mandates
though we still believe that a federal
vaccine mandate is very unlikely nate
let's hope this next strategy is our
best strategy and we all collectively
adopt it nancy thank you